To use Memcache using the Java native API, first
you get the Memcache service. You'll need to import the
Memcache service and the Memcache service factory into your
project and then you just use the getMemcacheService method on
the factory to get the Memcache service. Then to
put an entry into Memcache, you need a key. And
of course, a value to put and you just
call the put method. And to get the value out
of memcache, you need to know the key and
you just call the get method on memcacheService. If there
is no value in memcache with that key then null
is returned. Setting the announcement is something that we don't
want to expose through end points. We don't want other
people to be able to set the announcements for our
application. So we'll use a servlet in this case and
protect the URL for the servlet so that the app
itself can set the announcement but no one else can. Actually developers for the
application will be able to set the announcement but no one else will. So
you see here I implemented set announcement as a serve let.
Extends HttpServlet and I implements the doGet method. So here's
where I imported the MemcacheService and the MemcacheServiceFactory.
Here's where I get the MemcacheService and here's where I
put the value into memcache. Notice that this method doesn't
set the response so we set the response status to
204 which means that no response is expected. So if
you come here in the browser just stay on the
same page where you are. All this method does is
generate the announcement and save it in the memcache, it
doesn't return it. When you use servlet's in an app
engine application you need to configure them in web.xml.
So here's some mapping I added to web.xml for
the get announcement servlet. So here the servlet name
is set announcement servlet. And then here is the
class that implements the servlet and notice that I
put it in the servlet package. And then you
map the servlet name to the URL where it
gets called. So in this case, we're going to call
the servlet by going to crons/setannouncement. I also
defined a security constraint for my servlet because
I want to make sure that no body
except developers for this application can trigger the
servlet. How to find the resource name and
then the URL pattern that I'm protecting. Here
I've specifically protected /crons/setannouncement or I could just
protect everything under the slash crons path and
to specify the only admin that is developers of the application can trigger this
url. I set the role name to be admin. Right, wanted it so that any
logged in user could trigger it and all I would do is specify the
role name as asterisks but I don't.
I definitely want to restrict access to admins.